muy bien en este vídeo vamos a hacer un
ejemplo de una demostración por
inducción y en este caso vamos a
demostrar el ejemplo del inciso a este
dice si sumamos cuatro más 9 + 14 + 19 +
y así seguimos este hasta el término 5 n
- 1 esto debe ser igual a n entre 2 que
multiplica a 35 n muy bien y lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es verificar el
paso base vamos a tomar el caso cuando n
es igual a 1 muy bien el caso cuando ven
es igual a 1 del lado izquierdo
tendríamos que sumar 4 + lavadora hasta
el término 5 por 1 menos uno que éste es
4 es decir del lado izquierdo solo
tenemos el número 4 ahora veamos que es
del lado derecho entonces del lado
derecho tendremos un medio de 35 verdad
35 es 8 dividido entre dos es 4 entonces
podemos verificar que tenemos nuestra
igualdad verdad
entonces sigamos ahora con el paso de
inducción vamos a suponer que esta
afirmación que teníamos anteriormente es
cierta para el valor n igual acá acá
puede ser un número arbitrario verdad
vamos ahora a demostrar que es cierto
para n igual acá más 1 muy bien entonces
en esencia lo que suponemos es que 4 + 9
+ 14 más 19 más puntos suspensivos hasta
el término 5 por cada menos uno es igual
acá entre 2 que multiplica a 3 + 5 k muy
bien esto es lo que suponemos que es
cierto ahora lo que nosotros vamos a
demostrar es que 49 14 más 19 más puntos
suspensivos hasta 5k menos uno más el
siguiente término que corresponde a 5
que multiplica acá más uno menos uno
esto debería ser igual acá más uno entre
dos que multiplica a tres más
5 por acá más 1 y la verdad entonces
vamos a utilizar en esta en esta
expresión que queremos demostrar vamos a
verificar que se queda la igualdad y
vamos a utilizar la hipótesis de
inducción en los primeros términos
verdad porque desde 4 hasta 5 k menos 1
podemos utilizar nuestra su posición
anterior verdad la hipótesis de
inducción entonces esto de aquí vale acá
entre 2 que multiplica a 3 más 5 acá y
luego todavía tenemos que sumar el
último término que es 5 por acá más uno
menos uno muy bien y queremos ver si
esto es igual a camas o no entre 2 que
multiplica a 3 más 5 por cama son muy
bien entonces queremos ver si esta
igualdad de cierta así que vamos a
desarrollar un poquito del lado
izquierdo vamos a dejar que entre 2 que
multiplica a 3 + 5 k
ahora desarrollamos aquí verdad
tendríamos 5k más cinco menos uno
entonces esto en realidad es 5k más
cuatro verdad y queremos ver si esto es
igual acá más uno entre dos que
multiplica a tres más 5,5 verdad
desarrollando el producto
muy bien entonces la pregunta es será
cierto que son iguales estas dos
expresiones muy bien vamos a seguir
simplificando para ver si podemos
determinar esto entonces tendremos ahora
distribuyendo el producto del lado
izquierdo tendremos 3 camps entre 2 + 5
k cuadrada entre 2 + 5 k + 4 y queremos
ver si esto es igual acá más 1 dividido
entre 2 que multiplica a 8 más 5 acá y
el 8 lo obtuvimos de sumar tres más 5
muy bien entonces queremos ver si estas
dos expresiones son iguales así que
vamos a seguir simplificando y aquí por
ejemplo este término que es 5 acá en
realidad lo podemos ver como 10 k entre
2 verdad simplemente multiplicamos
digamos en un en una fracción por 2
tanto en el numerador como en el
denominador verdad nada más que el
denominador en este caso sería 1 muy
bien entonces si tenemos 10 acá entre 2
y 3 acá entre 2 tendríamos en total 3
seca entre 2 muy bien entonces
tendríamos aquí 3 seca entre 2 + 5 k
cuadrada entre
+ 4 y queremos ver si esto es igual a lo
que va a resultar de distribuir este
producto entonces tendríamos 8 que
multiplica acá más uno dividido entre 2
+ 5 k que multiplica acá más 1 dividido
entre 2 muy bien entonces vamos a seguir
simplificando para ver si tenemos la
igualdad del lado izquierdo tenemos lo
mismo 3 seca entre 2 + 5 k cuadrada
entre dos más cuatro y del lado derecho
tendríamos distribuyendo el producto
sería 8 k más entre 2 más 8 entre 2 + 5
k cuadrada entre 2 verdad más 5 k
dividido entre 2 y otra vez esto fue por
distribuir el producto del segundo
sumando muy bien ya casi llegamos al
resultado tendríamos del lado izquierdo
lo mismo 3 seca entre 2 más 5 k cuadrada
entre 2 + 4 y esto será igual a 3 seca
entre 2 porque sumamos el primer y el
último sumando verdad 8 y 5 nos da 13
multiplicando acá dividido entre 2
as el tercer sumando que es 5 k cuadrada
entre 2 + 8 entre 2 que es 4 entonces
como podemos ver las dos expresiones son
iguales verdad es decir son equivalentes
las dos expresiones y con este paso de
inducción y el paso base que teníamos
inicialmente hemos demostrado que la
afirmación original es cierta